une passion pour les chaussures plat
dans la mesure où ça a un côté androgyne
ce qui me plaît beaucoup à l'enfance
comme ça on ne sait pas vraiment si une
femme ouanna j'ai toujours peur dans la
rue quelque chose m'arrive et puis marc
est toujours quelque chose alors le fait
d'avoir des chaussures plates ça permet
de courir d'aller bien plus vite je ne
trouve aucun d'érotisme dans les
chaussures absolument pas la sociétaire
type pour moi j'ai petite culotte qui
ont la taille haut et qu'ils ont tant
field écosse et qu'est ce que je vous
embarque sur vos soro cheville envoyer
une petite croix parce que voilà j'ai
une passion pour les bondieuseries que
c'est comme les reliques voilà les
petites relie qu'est ce que c'est que ça
alors ça c'est du sang et puis des
petits morceaux de peau du ce nom oui du
sol qui goutte de sang et puis deux
petits morceaux parce que tout ça très
beau c'est facile sa cote est un petit
peu bizarre et j'aime bien ça géorgien
pression ça me porte bonheur on vous
aimez beaucoup aussi les cercueils et
les empires à vous nous enfermez les
vampires j'y crois et les horizontaux
nécessaire plâtre et rempile
[Musique]
ce